I want you back again
[Music]
hearing the first bars of a song by the
zombies can transport you right back to
the 1960s the band burst onto the music
scene just after the Beatles and like
the Fab Four many of their songs have
remained iconic long after they hit the
top of the charts well here's some of
those legendary hits in just a moment
but first I sat down with the band
members for a trip through their rock
and roll history well no the zombies
washed ashore in 1964 in the British
Invasion with their smash singles
she's not there
[Music]
she's not that
we were taking influences from all this
wide spectrum of music which gave the
zombies a unique sound
loved us although this it did make us
different the group came together in
hartfordshire England Easter 1961 we met
outside the blacksmith's arms of pub we
were too young to go into the pub and
were you 15 we were 15 rod argent was
putting together the band Colin
bloodstone arrived for his audition with
a rugby injury and he broken his nose
and he had two black eyes and I thought
Jim I was strapped right across the face
like this like a raccoon the zombies
became known for blunt stones stirring
vocals
and Argent's searing keyboard solos oh
no I would go up and down the the
keyboard like that yeah and my thumb
would be absolutely covered in blood by
these to gauge how well the gig is gone
by how much blood there was on the eye
they had a run of influential hits here
in the US but in 1967 just after
completing their album Odyssey and
Oracle they split you broke up just
because you weren't making enough money
we weren't making any money bloodstone
went looking for another job you had a
brief interlude in the insurance
business I did I worked in the burglary
department and you have to remember I
knew nothing about insurance so I can't
tell you what I answered the first phone
call then unexpectedly there single time
of the season soared to number one in
the States
[Music]
and bloodstone was coaxed back into the
music business did you guys think of
trying to reform or was it sort of too
late at night no it was never ever
discussed never we always wanted to look
forward and move on honestly argent was
having success with his own new band
and he and fellow zombie Chris white
co-produced Bloodstones early solo
records and so many respects we kept the
team together we just just changed the
name it would be 30 years before they
played together again in 1999 when
bloodstone needed a keyboard player I
called him out of the blue and I said
look I've got six dates what do you
think
and he came along and that magic was
still there
[Music]
zombies have been together ever since
releasing three more albums while
Odyssey and Oracle is now ranked by
Rolling Stone as one of the greatest
rock albums ever recorded it's
incredible and it was totally ignored at
the time but it sells more now every
year than it ever did in its first it's
a strange story well I mean I've heard a
lot of musicians from that period say
they didn't think it was gonna last I
mean the road we were walking along the
right way
all I said Tim you know rod if we go if
we can keep this going for two years and
we come out of this with five hundred
pounds each I wouldn't talk to about how
I took about ambition no one thought it
would last for 50 years and it's just
crazy